[Music]
in false hope news oh I get that all the
time
really how what happened because I think
I have too much of a big dream and then
I don't achieve it fast enough and I go
oh what which dream sure can
oh well that's one but I think that's
achievable another one is I want a 800
acre land that just got on for sale in
Maui but I don't have in Maui
how much is it it's like 20 million I
don't I don't have 20 million dude but
if you take out a loan and then you go
to Vegas all day smartest one know
you'll probably only get a loan that's
like not that much let's do it deal what
no alone put all together yep all in red
all on black but that's only if it's all
on green you only get you only get
double those so it's like if you put 1
million you only get 2 million hungry
and not lose if it gets nice too many
chances
it's like times 3 or some [ __ ] hungry
but if we all do it and we all win if
you get a number it's times 35 oh [ __ ] I
seen somebody do it while we were
playing roulette somebody yeah I was
with you yeah at the Caesars right I
think so yeah yeah so so we're just
playing right he puts a hundred bucks as
we're playing the ball is [ __ ]
rolling he puts it on one number boom it
hit I was like how did you get that it
goes I was just feeling it we were
playing on that table for a long time
tuna came out a nori $500
you cashed out and you left and I saw
him come back and his Playboy and I was
like ah this guy's gonna lose iPad oh so
much money out he's a dick tup mm-hmm
who does that walk up and put $100 on
one I did it I forgot if it was a number
of color but he put like a lot of money
and this one thing and I was like how
bar and he actually want my friend
colors different cuz I did that and I
and I was there too right yeah just two
to one has anyone ever asked the guy who
just lost like flipping a coin has
anyone ever asked a guy who just lost
like hey why did you do that and then
he's like I was just feeling it
same [ __ ] right but you can't walk
around with confidence though like that
you just know I was feeling it so what's
this story oh yeah what's the story
submitted by well done fries they're not
undercooked no me - I like undercut he
likes mushy okay I think it will soggy
dude we all had an argument with David
on our podcast the other day because
them - ganged up on me and lights crispy
fries you like crispy fries and I liked
soggy fries and then I would you talking
about mushy fries look oh you made a
mashed potato like no I mean a [ __ ]
french fry that tastes like I'm not
still inside yes potatoes she wants a
french fries like like a french fries
with a spray bottle down on it or
whether I wanna taste a fight that has
potato flavor yes yeah Chris was not
burnt or not there cuz it's so [ __ ]
crispy yeah yeah I hate that yeah it's
like a potato chip yeah it's got crunch
that's all I didn't have a Pringle then
we already did this in the park yeah but
now that everyone's on my side now
twenty-three-year-old claim to be a boy
that went missing seven years ago but
DNA tests uncovered an elaborate lie so
they were a girl the whole time
surprised I think it's just as he's just
claims actually register wasn't missing
but the perm like is still missing
all right the boy so he's a missing
picture and he's like oh that was me he
looks exactly the same
I've seen that picture Timothy Pizza
Pizza he went missing back in 2011 when
he was six years old his mom kidnapped
it or like took him out of school and
then she went around and took him to a
whole bunch of water parks and then it
ended up where she was founded like an
apparent suicide and she left a note
saying that Timothy was safe and in
someone's care and that he would never
be found
so since then the family has been
looking for him and then this 23 year
old named Brian who had just been
released from an Ohio prison less than a
month ago after serving time for
burglary and vandalism claimed to be
Timothy after he was found like just
lurking around she wanted to get the
family to take care of him he wants a
new identities um he's he's just not
mentally all there so him this is
Timothy he went missing and then they
did an age progression of what he would
look like after years later that's
trippy I thought it was actual guys i
was claiming i know i was like i looks
like his brother Timothy again with his
parents Oh dad is like devastated he
looks like his dad to this one what was
going on where she had to run away oh
yeah they don't look the same man he
looks like he liked us so you rose and
[ __ ] claiming to be a 14 year old but in
reality is a 23 year old beard gave me
to be 14 what the damn maybe maybe if he
was our meaning he would pass for
14-year old dude I refused a soccer
player in like Brazil that's so sad on
the parents though they're like oh by
the way we found your kid like hell yeah
it's psych what was it boy with Angelina
Jolie a she's like how am I so hot and
where's my son changeling or something
changed so good that oh dude what about
that sick Mel Gibson movie where he's
like get me back my shot and ransom yes
[ __ ] sick yeah I'll do the cat's all
day yeah but
my was more irrelevant to this boy yeah
cuz like her son went missing and then
they were like we found your son and it
was some other kid and she's like this
isn't my cell they're like yes it is
rabbits and [ __ ] my son get me my son I
want my son changeling movie children I
didn't like her [ __ ] team cuz it
brings a fake or another kid it's like a
tease your kids
it's another Cambodian well it's a
serial killer and he kidnapped all these
kids at once and like most of them were
dead but she was like some important
person so like they tried to get her her
kid back but the kid wasn't there
anymore cuz he was murdered and so they
gave her another kid and the kid was
like mommy mommy and like she he was
like playing the part for real
and then she's like this isn't my no
other you're not my son you're not my
son I want my son where's my son I'm a
mutt and then and then they're like
that's your son and they try to convince
her she was crazy
you guys seen Olympus is falling where
the White House is taking over our
Terrace and there's a part where the
Secretary of State won't give up the
[ __ ] nuclear codes or some [ __ ] and
then and then these Chinese guys like
start wrecking her whatever they start
like slap her in the face and [ __ ] she's
like spitting blood up yeah remember the
one movie the others yes
and then when like it's a ghost and then
then she was like what happened oh [ __ ]
I forgot the quote but then she ends up
going like no wait that was another oh
there was a Brittany Murphy movie that's
the what the Josh what's-his-name from
my desk kid The Mighty Ducks kid was in
the alt key or skeleton gang of some
[ __ ] what this guy think he's got to he
was the actress of the figures okay
Holmes Kate Hudson that's her name okay
you way off
it was way off yes she does pay
attention she hides him see her ears I'm
like wall would never notice oh she
ain't right yes they are thick is she
supposed to be your elf or a [ __ ]
resident those are her ears through that
one down bottom or the Rings oh the big
hoop earrings yeah that one oh yeah oh
how the cute dude did she get her ears
done bro because she looks like she
looks like a cheetah in Hollywood dude
she's had her ears tamed since then
those years have been tamed you know why
cuz her hair still big and curly that
ailing makes it look smaller
yeah did you know the bigger earlobes
you have more Richard you're technically
some like weird [ __ ] relationship
doesn't make any sense you know my ears
that's how um JLo's but made me feel
when I was growing up cuz I had a big
butt people with me front me in front of
it and then like and no butts weren't in
back then okay so you guys got a good
now but in the 90s big butts were out
and then that big butt song came out and
then it like that's when it started
getting closer to men ya know I grew up
around because in black so like booty
was always in I got made fun of having
our first girlfriend with a big butt Oh
see she's got a big butt I love that TV
it was all like blonde like skinny
blonde girls with big boobs big boobs
were in little big butts not in and then
I broke up with her because I was
embarrassed
black yourself everyone secretly likes
her but yep anyway we were talking about
crazy guys so again how good a question
in they're just saying that they did a
DNA test and then they were like that's
not him what if the DNA stuff is wrong
cuz he just macked with one of the
inmates all right just like a slow
kissed one of the inmates before he came
out and he spit in that thing and
they're like no son he was clean me
he had been held captive by these two
guys and um saying that they like one of
them had a tattoo like of a snake and
they only had a tattoo of like spiderweb
and then that luckily he was able to run
away and so they were looking at all
these different ends I he described
because he also described a vehicle but
obviously no one found anything because
he made it up and so yeah the family is
just like you know what don't send any
hate toward him like you know we feel
sorry for him he obviously needs someone
in his life to care for him that's why
he had to pretend to be Timothy but
we're never gonna stop looking for
Timothy I wonder what it's like to be
that crazy though I just as soon as I
heard that news it's like how can you
look at a person and go that was me why
are you trying to kill his dream my
dream Vicky that guy that 20 I know but
I'm just saying I want to live that I
know what that feels like I just want to
say 2,000 kids go missing a day in the
United States of America only 2,000 yeah
but that's a lot
do you like there should be looking
3,000 people died on 9/11 and we went to
war with everybody mm mm who doesn't
kids go missing a day okay so what's the
math behind that 2,000 times 365 can you
bust out of 1120 730,000 I just think I
nobody cares and open up it's on the
news every night the only kid currently
missing though in his area like this
region that's less than a percentage
though do when a plane goes down well
they go 300 people die or whatever the
[ __ ] right
how many gets found I don't know good
question because people could go missing
hmm but then the next day or a week or
whatever yeah probably not that many
good found I don't know I don't know man
that's almost a million kids I don't
know anybody that went missing well are
they all yeah where they found us
trafficking trafficking bro if I'm a
billionaire I'm gonna be like child
finder Batman oh yeah that's my job
that's tight I'm gonna use my special
skills to kill all the child brothel
owners I love it or maybe I won't kill
them I'll put them to work well I can of
those there are 152 115
stranger abduction cases every year
which means that the child is taken by
an unknown person so it sounds like the
majority of these are by people that
they but they know oh sure
damn man so I gotta trust my friends
less mm-hmm you can also be your
cousin's friends uncles aunts who knows
it could be mom yeah another yeah
exactly
good I think that's most of the time
actually could be yeah they're trying to
rape me from the mom like in this case
the mom took the kid and she couldn't
committed suicide too many man let me
know and nobody ain't nobody give a [ __ ]
that's my that's my that's why you don't
want well-behaved children because if
you have fucked-up kids nobody wants to
kidnap them nobody oh this one's trauma
they don't feel bad about torturing him
all right whatever mine and I'm walk on
this subject because a friend of mine
his brother went missing when he was a
teenager did he find out no never found
him oh that's [ __ ] up he's a UCLA and
he just started going to college and he
also he wasn't a child he was like a
teenager yeah but then yeah he um he
went missing in that room UCLA you know
he PI got drunk and then went swimming
in the ocean at night with his friends
and he what there was no friends he was
playing a video game late at night and
then he just went missing he the dogs
followed him to a bus stop and they
never found him crazy
[Music]